we welcome in studio for the first time
house
[Applause]
first I gotta I gotta give you a lot of
Applause because you have been
unrelenting in your Pursuit it's not
been easy to get those suspicious
activity reports it's not been easy to
get the FBI director to give you the
1023 form it's not been easy to get
these whistleblowers convince them uh
victims of Retribution to come talk to
your your committee and others yeah well
and remember with the suspicious
activity reports one reason they blocked
us early on Sean they said well there's
nothing to see here you won't find
anything well here's what we found when
we gained access to the suspicious
activity reports on the bidens we found
that the president did
have transactions that went to his
family members while he was vice
president that was something the media
said never happened they always said the
the wire transfers happened after he
left office we proved that they happened
while he was vice president and we
proved that nine Biden family members
were a part of the influence pelling
team not just the president's son and
they were funneling this money through
llc's they were friendly to LLCs we knew
about several of those seats but when we
got access to treasury we found more LLC
so we found more shell accounts more
bank accounts and more bidens who were
involved in the influent pilling team
now today we've requested more
information we're going to request more
suspicious activity reports relating to
barisma now I read today that barisma
money was funneled to China and then
returned to the bidens in the form of
quote loans is that to avoid taxes is
that a forgivable loan with no interest
like we had heard might have happened
with five million dollars do we know
anything about that all we know is in
the form 1020 the FBI form 1020 the 20
or 10 23 10 23. okay the oligarch
bragged that investigators it would take
10 years to find all the different
transactions that they gave that they
use to launder the money to the Biden so
we think they used through loans we
think they transferred to other
countries we think they transferred to
stocks we requested stock account in
addition to bank accounts so we're we're
going through this but we also have
information that would lead us to
believe there's information in
suspicious activity reports where Banks
realized what was going on they they are
pretty quick to catch money laundering
and that's what all the banks did in the
previous suspicious activity reports
they did these are LLCs that were not
legitimate businesses
receive money and redistribute money
absolutely Fair statement and when you
set up a bunch of shale companies for
the sole purpose of laundering money
that's called racketeering the banks
knew exactly what the buyings were doing
that's why they filed so many suspicious
activity reports against the bidens what
we're requesting now are suspicious
activity reports relating to anyone that
was involved in barisma because we
believe this will help us track the 10
million dollars that the oligarch said
he sent to both Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden so you're the chairman of the very
powerful and important House Government
reform oversight committee now uh what
do you make of these WhatsApp messages
the bidens are the best I know at doing
exactly what the chairman wants from
this partnership now that's a message
from Hunter uh to this Chinese Energy
company uh chairman that he's talking
about and they ended up getting you know
what a week after that that WhatsApp
exchange five million dollars less than
a week it shows that This president's
compromise that's why we're
investigating Joe Biden we believe
there's a reason that his families
received millions and millions of
dollars from our adversaries including
China we believe that he's compromised
and we believe that answers some of the
questions as to why he has energy policy
that puts America last and China first
this family's taken too much money from
too many of our adversaries around the
world for Joe Biden not to have to repay
them in the form of bad policy okay we
have six whistleblowers going before the
house Ways and Means Committee and
you're you're in touch with all of them
absolutely okay what do you make of this
other WhatsApp message I'm sitting here
with my father and we would like to
understand why the commitment May made
has not been fulfilled tell the director
that I would like to resolve this now
before it gets out of hand and now means
tonight he's like doing I want to say as
Vito Corleone that if this is not
resolved tonight I will do what I have
to do yeah uh and he goes on and he says
and Z if I get a call or text from
anyone other than you Zhang or the
chairman I will make certain that
between the Man City next to me Joe
Biden and every person he knows and my
ability to forever hold the grudge that
you will regret not following my
direction I am waiting I am sitting here
waiting for the call with my father well
that would be a direct implication of
Pops who's also implicated in the in the
laptop is given half his income to well
what we're going to see at this play out
in the house oversight committee is that
Joe Biden set up all of these deals
initially he was not only
not only did he know about him he was a
central figure are in them there's no
way China is going to send 5 million
dollars to Hunter Biden because he
threatened him in a text message it's
because Joe Biden had met with him first
and he had promised him things he'd
either already delivered and wanted the
payment or he was going to deliver and
the whole business model that China was
using the bidens for was to be able to
take Chinese money and start buying as
many Industries and as many businesses
in America as they could because there
were barriers Hunter had no experience
and energy no none none and it wasn't
just energy it was anything they could
invest in because there are barriers to
entry for China we don't want China
taking over important industries in
America they were using the Biden to
navigate The Journey expect from the
bidens I'm sorry what are the chairman
that they're kissing the ass of want
from the bidens they expected complete
loyalty and they expected them to
deliver on the on the money that they
had paid them they want access to the
government at the highest levels
chairman Comer great to see you in
studio appreciate it
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else